hello I'm Wesley Snipes
I want to talk about my friend Spike Lee
you don't know that this Spike Lee comes
from a village in Africa called Brooklyn
it is part of the West West Africa side
you know they have a lot of a pupil
there in this village they are known for
their artisans they are known for their
ability to do write scripts and the
ability to cinematographers yeah you
heard about this villager so I want to
say something about this spike is Iike
way mughal is a malcolm mandela that is
his real name how much of an inspiration
this man is to me he is an inspiration
because I learned a lot about patience
working with this man yeah a lot about
patience and I'm a good i'ma tell you a
quick stories and I'm going to give
these movie stars here their time a
couple of years ago I was with Spike and
I had the honor of coming with him to
the Oscars to represent the beautiful
Queen Mother Ruby Dee spike was her dead
and I was the bodyguard when after the
show they are washer and everything
happened and we're going out the way
they say we can go up to the party so
spike say Wesley come with me to the
party so I'm going to a party with spike
this is good yeah
do the governor's party we get up to the
desk and the little girl says excuse me
sir do you have your ticket and spike
says oh yeah we have our ticket he put
the ticket out but it's the wrong ticket
it doesn't have the little orange or red
strip on it you know to get upstairs so
the lady says do you have your ticket he
says this is the ticket he says no sir
this is not the ticket I'm sorry who are
you he says my name is spike she said
what do you say she say my name is spike
she says okay sorry I'm sorry sir if you
want a beverage you can go over there
they have the strike and coke and
whatever drink that you want over there
so I'm looking at this and I'm saying oh
my god they're not going to like let
spike bob says he turns to me he says
this is Wesley Snipes and she says who
are you so you know what happened they
didn't let us come upstairs to be born
for the Governor's Ball and we stand
downstairs there and I'm looking at I
can't believe it they don't let Spike
Lee upstairs okay so I want to say why
this is about perseverance and patience
because look at this yeah
sparkly I can't believe it
they didn't want you to come upstairs
before the yard but look at now they're
giving you a one
to all of you our actors to all of you
who are trying this business it is
important to understand that sometimes
you might not get to your word for your
craft your acting or your singing or
your dancing all you have to do is write
some screen write some code to virtual
subject matter say something that's
going to piss a lot of people off and
suit a letter you were to be here
getting an hour
good for you good for you going is a
true story
well here you have spike we're here for
you our partner pioneer phenomenon
prophet pain we love you
we're here for you Sam really yeah man
okay all right Spike Lee but for you
want anything you weren't throwing that
way
well what do say something yeah skip
listen up Spike Lee Denzel and I were
doing a soldier's play at the Negro
Ensemble Company when we met Spike Lee
right yeah he came to the play he told
us he was going to be a director real
like all right true said I'm at NYU film
school gonna move it right now joke bits
that bobbed up we could hit anyone yeah
all right
come down check it out I went down it
you go down at 9:00 I went down there
looking for
and he told me you know he was gonna
make a film coming up like I decide
Morehouse man we down okay great
mohawk yeah and then he made she's gotta
have it and I wasn't in it
I wasn't in it I wasn't minute Wesley
was you don't talk about the movies I
wouldn't alright so I said so that's the
same dude that came by and told her we
were gonna be in his movies right right
and we weren't in his movie right then
he started doing the next movie school
days I finally got a call and I worked
three hours on that movie so he's
looking out for his new house brother
right on brother
and he do the right thing but by Denny
actually had my phone number so spike at
this unique casting thing he would do he
would call sir spike do right there Jim
click
that mean I got a job sure enough I had
a job I did do the right thing next
summer turn spike let's bring good that
turned out to be mo better blues blue
did that next time send sprite jungle
fever trick but I was in rehab so
so thank God
spike didn't recast the road because I
was in rehab because I was actually in
rehab because I had done the research to
do jungle fever which actually worked
out very well for me which got me
actually got me to Hollywood which was
awesome
yep yeah baby yeah so thank you spike
for hanging in there with her brother
and uh getting me here but through all
that and through doing all those films
we all discovered that spike makes films
that are very personal to spike that he
hopes and audience will embrace but you
really think you care I mean he he wants
you to like his film and he wants you to
embrace them in a way but he tells
stories and he tells it in a way that he
doesn't really embrace the fact of
people's feelings being hurt he don't
pay nobody easy
well we did did you get paid I used to
steal Nike stuff out of the basement cuz
you had all that stuff stashed in the
basement so I'd go down and get some
shoes sure some you know but yeah
skel plus 10 still played me baby
but um spike spike spike makes films
from his heart
except for Inside Man which was like a
studio movie need yeah yeah we got paid
oh now got paid yeah I'll get they don't
know but um still getting paid he's good
okay how were you Internet no me me me
but spike has gone on to tell the story
of Katrina three little girls he makes
amazing amazing amazing documentary he
actually did a film about really we had
a really really great basketball player
to play for the Lakers for a long time
he's still playing for him but that's
another story and he makes these
wonderful wonderful films and
documentaries and he's he's told the
story of our people in his way and his
politics are the politics of I guess you
know an American anarchist in a way and
I like that about him I've always been I
guess on the other side of it also so
it's it's been a wonderful journey with
a wonderful friend who inspires me a lot
and it was always wonderful to have the
summer at Spike Lee's film camp with all
the wonderful actors that were around us
bill non-fish D Wes Giancarlo there are
a lot of people that have come out of
what spike started and allowed us to be
a bigger part of and learn how to work
in films that have become sort of
staples in this business that we have
called Hollywood so thank you for that
spike or
yeah in front of em behind ya Ernest
Ernest Dickinson a lot of people have
have done that and Mike Lee has put more
African Americans to work in this
business in this business than anyone
else in the history of this business
yeah that's right that's right and don't
call me Tyler Perry don't you call me
Mike was first Yeah right
and all those years when Spike made
those films that was so great like doing
the right thing
historical film mo better blues awesome
film
you know jungle fever awesome films
films that never were in 3000 or 2000
theaters but they had to compete with
films that work and they still made
money and they are still being watched
by audiences all over the world and he's
inspired an amazing number of young
african-americans and Hispanics and
Asian people to go out and learn the
film business and become film directors
because he made it viable to tell your
story your way
and for all those times that you didn't
get that statute spike and all those
other things that didn't happen your
community loved you and we still love
you and these days I haven't even
greater reason to love spike because he
actually directs my Capital One
commercials and oh yeah we're knocking
it out so now instead of me asking that
other question I can ask you to nice
bike what's on your metal please come
you see your honorary should be official
Academy Award for being just uh I'm
gonna say it
Hey